welcome to this video playing stilettos
rgv with that no name okay yeah can a
sharp opening be no need whatever you
can say about him is playing very
quickly I mean like move move move yeah
I think this is a theoretical position
to be honest so on it's not a big
surprise that is moving quickly and I'm
totally out of my knowledge here no idea
how this is played I normally play some
other line against the Benoni but I
wanted to try this one it's currently in
fashion this Bishop f4 line and black
normal equals with FF five stuff
came
and again a couple of ideas I can go
look be one to go for B form before kind
of approach not sure that this is the
right kind of position for that to be
honest well I think currently if equals
B 5 I can take a plug is heaven anyway
which of course is totally ignored we
can take with an idea maybe this is the
idea
ok
k 12 is not not doing that much with the
pond or III there is no light coming to
d4 or something like that maybe Bishop
f5 is a move him to provoke you form
yeah and you see it right after you
played it well at this day six is
hanging now
you fall night your fork removes and
well he can go noise still I'm not
winning a 6mm and Queen a4 is probably
shooting 493 ok I thought I can take a
six hey this is just wrong I didn't see
him move with this annoyed and t3 is
hanging
maybe you can play Knight c3 Queen d3
rugby to Ian whereas Nazi for the end ok
that's not going to work but it's a wow
ok and now if I just play Queen a five
or something like that one Knight f3
where's he going after Knight f3 with
the Queen
like to take b5 and possibly g6
and gas plot Queen f6 maybe or they're
okay or take that now
it's not so easy i mean it's it's nice
to have that porn but it's not a simple
technical task so taking be to I wonder
can I do something active here look to
you one or something what is he doing
then it should be for now I cannot do
that if I go look T 1 where's he putting
his Bishop Bishop c4 there's be three
24 or something I thought b3 why not
should we should win a piece so somewhat
strange tactical motif but likes pieces
are just to lose
now just a piece that was a very strange
game yeah I've been nonius a very very
tough opening to play with both colors
where's that person by the way it's no
name yeah
tick tock tick tock it's a clock run
down
yeah I don't know does he feel like he
spoiled a great position or something I
don't know I really couldn't figure out
what was going on or is he just
disconnected black for offense on time
nope just let let the clock run down
instead of resigning like a proper
person okay so we had this this opening
which is this a serm theoretically line
I think it's kind of normally I I really
wouldn't read know how this is played
Bishop everyone yeah I thought that'd be
five isn't that great but well he we
played it anyway and the engine approves
the computer wants to go f4 in this
position just pushing hey of course it's
an option if I get any five hits
brilliant but Janet's and of course it's
completely completely wired now it looks
it looks dangerous this is the computers
line with an advantage to white but
nothing substantial yeah it's very sharp
okay I went here be 5a be he took with
the night I was thinking if he does this
I had Luke a seven but the computer is
completely unimpressed and says that
this is good for black yeah yeah it
probably is why is pretty active it's
pretty active and if i take now that
that didn't make make much sense and
came took with this quincy tool and I
didn't really see that coming only after
a plate Quincy to it's pretty
embarrassing the engine like c4 though I
didn't like this because of 94
that felt that this shouldn't be right
computer wants to go fo and things I'm
better okay I don't go I am I don't buy
it yeah this is always compensation for
black okay the computer basically agrees
gives just a slight edge toward okay I
went here and 93 takes to take so and
now it no it gets gets critical ok
computer gifts gives equal which is good
because I had some doubts am that that I
might be even in some kind of some kind
of trouble here rook FDA does the engine
move and this is just plain weird but
should be five why would you trade that
okay well he thought that maybe 9 p-5
and 36 was hanging but trading that
Bishop can never really be a good idea
yes all this this I take the computer
wants to go E 4 and gives ridin pretty a
pretty good advantage yeah well taking
it's not an option I take thee three
then this is just a pawn idea that this
is just a mistake I guess I'm root g one
and he has to play that move that i
mentioned queen you fall that's the only
moved to avoid immediate material loss
but i have a very strong move here oh
wow i doubt that i would have found that
at least not in a blitz game before
that's very strong
always impressive a move that puts upon
on a square that is protected three
times and no capture works now once you
see it it's kind of kind of clear that
it works but a tough I don't know I mean
I saw the b3 move here so maybe I would
have seen before but before it's much
more difficult than this is this be
three more interesting game anyway okay
well thanks for watching